[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
i'm piers morgan on sensor coming up
tonight the king of the ring is back for
round two tyson fury remains uncensored
and this time he's bringing his wife
paris with him
uk government has spent half a million
pounds of taxpayer cash on not sending a
plane with any asylum seekers to rwanda
you might share my view that is insane
and our robots the real threat to
mankind the google engineer who created
one warned it came to life with thoughts
and feelings what the hell does this all
mean
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well good evening several weeks today
fresh from his knockout win over dillian
why in front of 94 000 spectators at
wembley the heavyweight champion of the
world tyson fury looked me and looked
you in the eye and announced to the
world he was not going to fight again
well let me tell you something pierce
morgan uncensored this is the truth the
gospel truth nothing but the truth i'm
done
you know every good dog has its day and
like the great roman leader said
there'll always be somebody else to
fight when is enough enough i'm happy
i'm healthy i've still got my brains i
can still talk i've got a beautiful wife
i've got six kids i've got obtained
belts i've got plenty of money success
fame glory
what what more am i doing it for
well this morning in the sun newspaper
tyson gave a little hint
that it may not be
completely out of the question that he
might come out of a time for a reported
200 million pound fight to unify all the
titles so what's changed i would like to
say that tyson is joining me with the
beautiful wife paris that he talked
about in our last interview good evening
to both of you
good evening pierce hello there now
tyson i've got one question to ask you
when you looked me in the eye
those weeks ago yeah you vowed you were
never ever going to fight again
did you mean it
yeah yes
yeah
so you're not gonna fight again
no i still mean it pierce
so when you're not gonna be fighting any
more professional fights i'm finished
what happens if the joshua yousek fight
in august in saudi arabia is a bit of a
thriller and joshua wins
and the jungle drums begin beating that
the whole of britain wants to see you
finally get in a ring with anthony
joshua and frank warren being the
brilliant promoter that he is
puts a check on the table in front of
you
for such a gargantuan summer money you
think you know what i've got one bit of
unfinished business and it's joshua
no you know i don't care who wins out
the fight i wish i'm both luck in the
world um i'm done i told you i was done
seven weeks ago i meant it there's some
talk of me having some exhibition fights
but to be honest with you i can't see
that coming off either um i've got no
real interest in fighting anymore um
it's not just the fight on the night
it's all stuff in the gym taking punches
to the head
it's just enough is enough for me um i
put a ridiculous number on today i said
i'll come back for half a billy half a
billion pounds that's 500 million so if
that's not ridiculous
ridiculous enough to believe i'm not
coming back for boxing i don't know what
is but somebody and franklin warren is a
good provider but somebody might get
somebody might get that number for you
they might get that number for you if
they do
if they do if they say look
half a billion would you take it
yeah
listen i would definitely look at it if
there's half a billion on the table just
look at it
you'll have to look at that offer just
have a look so paris you're not going to
see it
for billy well let me come to your wife
who i suspect you know probably wears
the the rings in this in this marriage
paris
how would you feel because i know after
the wilder trilogy he vowed he wasn't
going to fight again and you well you
believed him and he did then fight again
well after the first fight
yeah do you think he means his first
fight wilder i begged him not to fight
again and then he obviously fought on
and he had the trilogy and then he's
fought again just the other day in
wembley and he says he's definitely
quitting and he's definitely finishing
on top but
there's just still a glint in his eyes
that i see
and i just i just don't know i'd like
him to retire everybody in his family
we're all happy with everything he's
done and he's just obviously he's done
amazing but
i just
don't know there's something in the back
of my mind that thinks tyson's still
itching for certain fights
we're here honestly this is why and he
tells me no
and i would love to believe it
but i'm just not quite there i think i'm
with the rest of the public thinking is
it true you see paris this is why i
wanted you in this interview because the
wives always know
tyson if it was just me and you i'd be
taking all this at face value but the
woman you love who you live with who
knows you better than any person alive
she sees that glint in your eye
and she thinks there's unfinished
business
okay i'll ask her a question while
you're on paris yeah do you want me to
fight again for any amount of money no
yes or no no well 100 million or 200
million change our lives not at all but
when have you done what i've asked you
to do
he always does what he wants to do he
will only do what he wants to do whether
it pleases me him or everybody he's only
going to do what he wants to do and what
if i said i'm not going to fight i said
warren i've told bob arum i've told
everybody tyson fury and fighting is
finished
the money is not tempting to me to be
fair
um
but there's something still calling you
out there because the other day you were
saying oh i want to do expeditions i
don't i might do this and i might do
this
like a crazy trojan yeah but i do train
for my mental health and emotional
fitness and everything else but the fact
of the matter is
i might might do an exhibition
exhibitions are not real fights just
pretend play time showtime entertainment
but there's still something calling you
there and i just wonder i never you
never know i i hope you retired and i
hope it stays that way but it's one of
them
we'll wait and see it
i'll have to wait do i have to stay out
the ring before i'm officially retired
then i don't know i think he was retired
for 10 minutes on box rep wasn't it well
i have been out the ring before for
three years
three years and i came back tyson i've
never seen ever but it
tyson we're just gonna we've got a
slight issue with your microphone so i'm
gonna talk to paris and we're gonna go
full screen with paris here while we fix
your mic and then we'll come back to
paris paris is actually doing a
brilliant job on my behalf getting the
truth out of you so we're going to come
just to paris for a moment apparently
yeah
and we're going to fix tyson's might
while we do okay so paris his his
what i want to talk to you about you
first met tyson when you when you were
what age
uh 15. 15 years old 15 hours peers
you've had a remarkably
long successful not always perfect
marriage
to somebody who is i think one of the
most unique people i've ever met in
sport
uh uniquely smart uniquely fascinating
uh you know had his troubles always talk
so openly about them what's it been like
to be with tyson all this time and how
have you seen him evolve
um tyson has always been up and down and
always been this crazy lovable person
that he is
and he's evolved in the fact that i
think he's matured which i do think all
men take a little bit longer to do and
he is now
happy and content in his life and i
think that's why he's retired i think
that's why in his heart and soul he's
happy with everything he's done and the
career went great everything that he
ever wanted to do and told me all them
years ago even as a young boy at 15 or
16 he told me i'm going to be
heavyweight champ of the world i didn't
really believe it i didn't didn't
believe that he couldn't do it i just
thought he'd probably get picked up in
other things and but tyson has done it
and i think he's happy and contented
which has made our life just brilliant
and everything's running really well
we've got six healthy children we're
happy and we're doing great so
to tick all the boxes he's done that and
he's contented with his career and his
life of what he's done
but
as the wife i just
i just look and i just wonder are you
doing as much as everyone else and i
hope he is i hope that with like
boxing's done and he chooses another
path and finds something that he's
passionate about and carries on with it
but
will he stay out the ring i honestly and
we're sitting here together and whatever
whatever we say afterwards but i do
think there's a question mark there
i do too we're gonna take a short break
when we come back i'll be back to you
tyson with some more tough questions on
piers morgan uncensored
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to peterborough censored
here's round two with tyson paris fury
tyson i think we've got you back on a on
a proper mic again which is good we can
hear you loud and clear so look your
wife's having none of this she sees the
glint she thinks there's unfinished
business
and i'm with paris on this
yep are you with a lot of other people
as well it's me dad my lawyer my wife
well me and the lawyer have a bet don't
we yeah i i just think i'm the only
person who actually believes in what i'm
saying you know a lot of people say no
tyson fury doesn't know when he's
telling the truth himself but you know
the word can be me bond and it can be
tried and tested the future will will
tell if i'm telling the truth or not how
about this how about given if you do
fight again you're going to get a barrel
load of
cash
gazillions how about if you do fight
again you have to give me a million
pounds
how about that's a deal really can i
join in on that yeah you can have a
million pounds as well paris so we have
a deal do we you'll give me a million
quid if you fight again if i'm getting
half a billion yeah exactly yeah i'll
give you a million quid i get paris one
two all right
i love that deal because i've got a
feeling we're going to cash in paris
what's a million pounds of [ __ ]
like me can you please around me
tyson i have to now apologize for your
bad language you're a very naughty boy
oh
i thought this was uncensored morgan
still
let me ask you hypothetically if you
were to fight again
if
the fight was going to be say in saudi
arabia you know all the fuss that's
going on currently with this sports
washing as they call it and particularly
about the golfers you've taken money to
play in a saudi-backed tournament what
do you feel about that i i personally i
wrote a column today for the new york
post fantastic
sorry we're gone yeah that's a fantastic
question pierce because isn't our own
government trying to strike a deal with
the saudi saudi to get a better oil and
gas rate at the moment yes as are the
americans so how can anyone say anything
about a sports deal when everybody's
clamoring to saudi to get a better deal
on oil prices well this is what i wrote
in my column for the new york post i
think there's so much hypocrisy around
this you know you've got the next world
cup coming this autumn in qatar for
example you know uh formula one has
races in saudi arabia uh a lot of uh
sporting bodies do business with china
huge business with china which also has
appalling record of human rights i guess
my question for you
do you feel there should be any moral
line is there any way you wouldn't feel
comfortable fighting
you know for me pierce i can only take
people as i find them
and no matter what somebody else says
about you
i will judge you on the way you are with
me
and i would like to think you would do
that with me yeah so no matter what
anybody else has about you pierce i like
you
[Laughter]
but
i i only take people as i find them you
know what i'm saying i'm the same
so i don't listen to rumors and all that
stuff all the rubbish that goes with it
i take people on face value on how they
are as as people would be and if i
haven't had any dealings with these
people i can't really have a comment
does that make sense i think it makes
perfect sense and i think the whole
sport watching thing is riddled with
hypocrisy let me ask you tyson when you
when i i just really got pass it's all
go on go on go on continue no no you're
the chat i think it's only
it's yeah it's only like oh it's a big
scene when it's it's not the right
person who's doing it
if it's the government who's doing oil
and gas deals it's fine if it's the
sports star making a fortune it's bad
you know i don't know where it all all
ends and all starts it's like what's
good for one is good for the gander
sports for the full world sport
shouldn't be just for one country or
anywhere else this you shouldn't
discriminate anybody that's right sports
is for the world to see
together that's what it's all about i i
absolutely agree i think it's all
completely hypocritical the whole debate
if governments are prepared to treat
these countries like saudi arabia as
allies and buy oil and trade arms with
them i don't think that sportsmen should
be held to this kind of ferocious
account for their supposed immorality if
this is what their own governments are
doing all the time um let me ask you uh
tyson
about uh love
because you're a passionate man you're
an emotional man and you've got this
beautiful woman that has been with you
since you were both very young what has
been the secret of your romance together
i think i'm very qualified to speak on
the matter of love because
i've been married 13 nearly 14 years
this year started as kids together from
15 16. six kids and all that so yeah i
think
love is a fantastic um
thing if you can ever find love in your
life whether it's you're loving someone
or you have a love for something
it's a fantastic fantastic thing and
someone who's never experienced love can
have the world but they'll have nothing
to love affair with like sports and me
yeah i mean tyson have you have you ever
been in love with anybody else or has
paris been the one always for you
paris has been my first love and only
love as in a person
but i have
i've had a
a really vicious
love affair
keep going we're boxing
on and off my whole life
paris when you hear
paris when you hear this this this man
mounted this this world heavyweight
champion this all-time great of the
sport when you hear him being so
romantic how does it make you feel
do you know what pierce you've got to
take in fact that tyson's just my
husband it's not heavyweight champ it's
not nothing special like yes i can
credit him and say he's done really well
but the end of the day me and him has
just been together for being kids and
i don't look at him in that light so for
him to say that i think well yeah that's
good that's lovely of course a husband
should love his wife and vice versa you
should love the person you're with you
should love your partner no matter what
so
that's obviously a bit given isn't it
you can't really be with someone if you
don't want to be with them and you don't
love them and paris what are the best i
don't look at it later it's one of those
big fighters
what are the best and worst things about
tyson from a wife's perspective
be honest now because we're on the pace
morgan show we're here to tell the truth
the truth is uncensored the bestest
thing is house yeah
is how
crazy and
spontaneous and
outgoing and
talkative and everything he has with him
that's the greatest side of him
and then that's also the worst side of
him because that has two sides of the
table you've got the great sides of like
right come on we're going somewhere
today and everything's happy but then
you've got the the other side that's
like hey wake up come on get up get
packed i want to leave i'm going to
china tonight so you've got the good and
the bad and
i i don't know i can't say the bad or
the good tyson's obviously had his ups
and downs and we've been through it all
together so
we're just through it through thick and
thin aren't we i just you're a fantastic
i think you're a fantastic couple i do i
i've and i know it's not she's like my
ride ride or die
she's my ride or die chick pearce
let me ask she's the one when i do the
bank robbery she's driving the car
let me ask you tyson when i did
celebrity apprentice in america uh with
lennox lewis we were we were stuck
together for about six weeks and became
good friends and i got a lot of time for
lennox but he told me when he was the
heavyweight champion of the world when
he used to go out clubbing especially in
sort of new york and so on uh the
biggest guy in every place they went at
some stage of the night would come and
try it on want to have a fight
do you get that
yeah
do you know what great question
no i don't get it anywhere because i
don't walk around like i'm a heavyweight
champion of the world i've not got a
chip on my shoulder and my aura is come
here i want to give you a hug and think
he was hung my auras not let me punch
you in the face i'm a tough guy
so never once in my whole life yeah i
can vouch for that i've never ever seen
it no one has ever approached me for a
fight or approached me in the aggressive
manner no because i'm not that i've not
got that aura or edge on me where i need
to prove myself or whatever you're not
like aggressive macho man are you no i'd
rather just sing and dance and have a
beer and whatever else well i'll tell
you why i was asking because um as you
may have seen the the boxer julius
francis who actually fought mike tyson
um he was now he's now doing security
and he got into this incident a couple
of days ago just show a little clip this
is a box park at wembley
[Applause]
now it's interesting he's
they aren't going to charge him with
anything for this even though he's not
the guy out i watched the whole video
this guy was abusing julius francis
abusing everybody else and eventually he
looked like he was threatening julius
francis and julius chin did what did you
make of that
yeah
you know
all of it i saw the video i've seen it
i've seen the knockout great right hand
by the way um
but you know this is what happens when
you're cheeky rude getting in people's
faces punching them whatever what do you
expect
if you keep kicking a dog it's going to
bite you isn't it
and you know these guys are there doing
a job there wasn't all on the lash
together this guy's probably pissed off
or whatever had a few drinks
get cheeky these guys are doing their
job he's attacking them whatever so he's
been chinned
um
and that's a life lesson in it
never go out and be cheeky to big men
because you're probably going to get
chinned
i love the fact that uh tyson
well other fact you said he'd rather
sing because i recently interviewed as
you know don mclean the great uh
american singer-songwriter who gave us
american pie here's what don mclean said
about you
after you gave us that kind message
i was going to tell tyson i love to meet
him someday i love him he is what boxing
has needed um
he is a lovable champion and he's a
great champion and i wanted to tell him
that um whenever i get in trouble now
i'm going to say that i have him as my
best friend and i'm going to warn
anybody who's trying to mess with me
that i have him on speed dial you know
what i mean
what do you think of that tyson
i said don's a great guy i only spoke to
him yesterday on instagram he said he's
over in the uk november december so i
said let's hang out and have a beer so
this is crazy i'm going to be having a
beer with don mclean i'm probably
singing uh a version of american pie
together again well this yeah the
american pie song that was released
recently
featuring myself and don yeah it's um
it's won a load of awards so yeah good
do you feel like giving us a little
burst now time for someone that can't
really sing
what would you like to wear i'd like to
hear a bit of american pie please
so bye
bye mr american pie drove my chevy to
the levee but the levee was dry
them good old boys were drinking whiskey
and right
singing this will be the day that
this is like the ongoing anthem in our
house the kids even sing it now i love
it you know i absolutely love those
songs piss
do you know what is crazy though
like everyone keeps telling tyson you're
a great singer a great singer now he's
good he's okay but they're actually
offering him record songs now record
labels are coming to him and offering
him songs and albums
he can't sing what are you
doing who is listening to this song i
i'm a bit of a
bit of a negative one on that one she's
negative on that one now paris on a more
positive note there are rumors swirling
that there may be another addition to
the fury household can you say anything
about that
ah i've heard about these rumors for
about
four two months now
i'm sure just clarify yeah you can it
ain't true oh
i've heard this for months and i keep
leaving it and i keep thinking where are
they going to wake up i have lost a good
bit of weight recently i'm feeling
pretty body proud
and it's like everyone keeps saying
she's pregnant she's pregnant no no no
we've got six and we're happy with that
number right now well you look fantastic
and tyson as you know you are batting
away
put it this way pearce yes we will have
another child before i fight again
that's a guaranteed fact well i've got
listen if you fight again i've got my
million quid coming my way uh but tyson
i think you would accept that you are
me too
to use the the the vernacular phrase
tyson you are punching way above your
weight i think you'd agree right
thank you very much pierce he won't
agree because he's he's a he's a very
competitive guy that'll never happen
he'll never agree
i agree my wife is is she's fantastic
she's had six kids she's that's alive
she's probably at about 10 that we've
lost a few as well along the way
she is a full-time mother housewife
everything she's the best-selling author
she does so many things and she looks
fantastic so you know
i've done all right i used to look good
when i had hair and all i bought now i'm
like the beast from the east
the big old ugly ball did it fella oh i
make it with it
in character in character
in my character i look like brad pitt
uh i've got to mention your talk i can
talk to you guys all night but sadly i
have to leave it there you've got a new
talk coming fury fest the official after
party tour it would include a meet and
greet with with you with a q a and more
the first day i think is this friday in
london tickets are on sale now give me a
quick um sort of early preview of what
it's about tyson
it's you know it's about the the boxing
career it's the mental health um story
it's everything you know give people an
opportunity to come and sit down and
listen maybe they're suffering with
mental health the self maybe they're
having boxing funds or maybe they just
want a fantastic night so if you haven't
got tickets already get tickets there's
only 16 shows on the first leg
um and i'm selling out really quick so
get yours right now brilliant tyson
paris what a pleasure to talk to you
both really loved it you were both
gloriously uncensored please come back
again soon it's always great to have you
on the show
thanks very much page for always having
us on you are the best and you're
watching piss morgan on sexy
guitar
i love it chad i love it
great to talk to you both all the time
bye guys
bye now bye-bye thank you
brilliant absolutely brilliant i love
thai stuff and i love paris fury what a
wonderful couple aren't they
uh brilliant anyone said next as the uk
government remains committed to the
failing rwandan migrant plan i'll debate
this with talk tv host julie harper
former labour minister stephen pound
australian senator jim molin who led
their country's offshore migrant scheme
and the former uk home office minister
anne whitaker
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back pretty patel is bound to
push through the rwanda migrant plan
despite being forced to cancel the first
deportation flight after an intervention
by being court of human rights and
british courts labor now accused of
secretary of wasting half a million
pounds of taxpayers money on charging a
jet that she knew would never take off
to discuss all this i'm joined now by
today's pierce pack talk tv host julia
hartley brewer former labour mp stephen
pound as well as former home office
minister ann whitaker australian senator
and retired major general jim mullen who
helped craft australia's offshore
processing policies so a stellar panel
today uh let me start with you ann
whitaking
this to me look like a total fiasco
the home secretary charges a plane for
half a million pounds of taxpayer cash
the plane ends up with no asylum seekers
on board and ends up flying not to
rwanda but to spain
a complete fiasco total way to taxpayer
cash
okay calm down peers
if this policy succeeds and i believe it
will it's going to save us millions
indeed billions of pounds
so it was well worth that drop in the
ocean
uh and what pretty patel was doing and i
think she was right she was saying as
long as there's any chance at all and
the british courts were after all ruling
in our favor
as long as there's any chance at all of
getting migrants on that plane then it
is worth trying now the government has
been upfront throughout and has said
that it expected legal challenges that
expected problems it didn't expect an
easy run to this policy but it's got to
carry on and it's got to be determined
and and that would be the message i
would send out now were i sitting around
the cabinet table stick with it all
right stephen powell is going to save us
billions
absolutely it's a reasonable nonsense
look we've been there we've tried this
before um the israelis deported i think
it was about 40 000 people um to africa
between 2014 and 2017
all of them left what we have saw
yesterday was more gimmicks this is
absolutely absurd this is like boris
island or the you know the bridge acro
across the rsc it's absolute nonsense
the main statistic is pearson you know
as well as i do yesterday 444 plays nil
444 people landed on the south coast of
england we have no control over our
borders because we don't have any system
of internal identification cards no
people left i'm sorry we should be
concentrating on serious responses
rather than these ludicrous ridiculous
cruel gimmicks but what is the serious
response the seriousness about threefold
first firstly we work with the french
instead of abusing it
they're not interested but french are
interested because there are you know we
can process people within france but if
we're talking about deportation rather
than actually asylum and immigration
then we should actually say we should
process people here we've got any number
of flipping islands around here we can
get on the island of white or the of man
right i mean julia this is an
interesting point why aren't we doing
this say on the isle of wight which is
on our doorstep would presumably cost a
lot less money don't think the people on
the isle of wight are very keen on it
look this is such nonsense this idea
that we should be working with the
french i mean they've been trying to
work with the french quite a long time
in the europe and the and the european
union they they don't want to help all
we get for is insults and and threats
for emmanuel macron the reality is
they're not going to do anything in the
french to stop these people getting in
these rickety boats and paying thousands
to people traffickers and they won't
take these people back when we what do
you think what do you think of rwanda
it's not a country i've been to i'd
quite like to go there on holiday see
what it's like but given that the you
know the european court of virginia is
about a bad country i don't think
there's any reason for us to think that
you've been calling so why would
so why is it a deterrent
it's a deterrent you don't get to be in
britain why is it a deterrent from
people coming from france that people
who are arriving
why would it act as a deterrent because
the point is when you arrive on the
shores you come on those ricky boats you
come illegally you don't get to stay
here and even if you are found to be as
many of these people are to be a
legitimate asylum seeker you don't get
to stay here why wouldn't you want
legitimate asylum seekers to stay here
because we're looking at
almost unlimited numbers and the issue
that labour have got when they come up
against this it may be a bit of a
gimmick this policy the problem is the
problem you've got is that how many how
many would you stop the numbers at uh is
it how many would you take of these if
you have safe routes and legal routes
and people how many ukrainians have we
currently taken in i think we've taken
in a few hundred no about isn't it 75
000 something like that that's a lot of
people right it's a lot of people coming
here on a temporary basis to have refuge
while well we don't know how long
they're going to be here very different
from people who've traveled across
what's seen okay what is the actual
difference between people fleeing war in
ukraine and people who are fleeing war
in syria afghanistan iraq and iran which
is where the vast majority of the people
on the boats are coming from yeah i
think i think it's very difficult to say
what is that what is the real difference
the point is why are we treating one
group with great empathy and sympathy
there are there is why are we treating
all the others with you're going to
rwanda there are safe routes for people
to come from a lot of the countries the
people who are getting on those boats
they actually are able to come through
safely a lot of those young men who are
getting off those boats 90 of them are
young men under 40. uh they wouldn't be
getting us approval asylum if they
applied from their own country okay i
want to bring in uh major general uh
mohammed first of all thank you very
much for joining me uh from australia
major general great to talk to you
thanks pierce thank you now you you
oversaw this um operation in australia
where you basically have the same
problem a lot of people coming in or
trying to come in illegally to australia
uh using boats on the water again you
had the people smugglers the trafficking
and so on and it was pretty draconian uh
the way that australia went about this
but indisputably in terms of stopping
the boats incredibly successful the
downside from what i could ascertain
from studying this was that the places
that they were being sent the detention
centers they were being placed in
the conditions were not very good and
that people were having a bad time there
talk me through from your perspective
how it works
uh pierce uh the main thing behind our
approach to this particular problem was
exactly what anne said and that is
resolve
we had the resolve we had about 80
percent of the australian population
backing the government at the time the
government internally was solid and i
think that is the single most important
thing if pretty patella is prepared to
continue to try
and if she can portray it because it is
not a spin but because it is as both
effective in that you control your
borders and humane then that's very very
important uh i i i don't believe
that uh the places that we sent
uh the what we call illegal maritime
arrivals and i just listened to another
debate on another network and they were
all calling them refugees now these
people are not refugees we chose the
term illegal maritime arrivals
because you can only come into australia
through
legal ports of entry therefore that's
indisputable
uh the people are not uh refugees uh but
we still assess them very very seriously
before they were sent everywhere so uh
we we designed this pla this policy and
it had three legs the first one was that
we were prepared to turn the boats back
we had a lot more sea space in which to
turn the boats back than the english
channel
but that was very contentious and it
only worked once there was a lot of
publicity and that the the people were
arriving back in indonesia uh uh or in
sri lanka and there's a lot of publicity
surrounding it the second thing was that
we finished the processing of the
migrants offshore so they were never
subject to the activists and activists
god bless them that's their right to be
activists but are they serious they hold
serious concerns if it was illegal we
would not have been able to do it if it
was inhumane we should not have done it
but the activists will always say
they've got serious concerns we've all
got serious concerns this is hard and
tough policy and the third part the
third part of our actual offshore pr or
the third part of our border control
policy was uh the fact that we only ever
those that did get through and got onto
the mainland because we excised certain
areas from our legislation those people
that got here were only ever given
temporary protection visas and not a
higher level of visa that would open
them up to
to activist legal action would you say
would you say
i understand you you always believe
fermi you had to have all three for it
to work when you look at what the
british government is trying to do
do you see flaws in this system
obviously they're facing huge resistance
from the european court of human rights
and some british courts as well getting
involved with some of the asylum seekers
yesterday but do you see flaws in the
way we're going about this system
well and and are these flaws but some of
those flaws uh are
are the result of geography and areas
such as that i mean if you have islands
that that you can excise that's a long
process in itself and and that may or
may not be possible
which then keeps the illegal maritime
arrivals away from the legal system
within the uk that might work the
greatest opportunity that europe and the
uk missed in controlling this was that
you didn't do this during uh when people
were moving across the mediterranean and
thousands more died the great moral high
ground that we were able to occupy was
that we stopped people dying at sea
twelve hundred people died 50 000 came
to australia
uh
in 600 boats uh and 1200 died at sea and
we pulled them our navy pulled them out
of the water half eaten by sharks and
and rotten by by by drowning
and that was the moral high ground it's
got to be legal and it's got to be
humane and the humanity appears is that
by having this tough policy we could
still offer to people who are really
refugees permanent residency okay our
permanent residency we're in the top
three or four four countries in the
world very interesting uh actually the
way australia went about this not
without its own controversy but
certainly very effective in stopping
people i mean hardly any votes now try
and get in i know there's been one or
two recently but it's a tiny tiny number
that try and they're clearly being
deterred let me go back to around
whitaking i'm gonna give it the
government seems to me one of the issues
that they've got here is on the one hand
they're trying to present rwanda as a
great place to go you know post the
genocide different country very
welcoming and so on and so on on the
other hand they're they're trying to
also make out it's a deterrent to be
sent there you can't be both can it well
look france is a great country france is
a lovely place to live but they're still
all trying to get out of a get out of
france to get here now why is that piers
and it's very straight forward
france has a very tough approach to
asylum if their claims are flimsy they
know they're not likely to be allowed to
stay but the message has gone out for
years now not just under this government
under successive governments the message
has gone out for years now
if you get into britain you're very very
unlikely ever to be removed and that is
where the deterrent effect comes in that
when you land on our shores the next
stop can be rwanda okay julian
final point to you and steven here i
mean
interesting how australia went about
this interesting also with israel and
africa it didn't really matter it's
abandoned it of course now well but it
has because
well actually because the boat stopped
coming i mean it's indisputable to both
stop coming there are definite issues
about where they were putting people and
the conditions they held them in but
they certainly stopped people coming on
the boats we don't know what the cause
and effect is that we we just simply
can't tell you the thing with
immigration is it's push and pull um if
the push is obviously as you've
mentioned if somebody's fleeing the iraq
and stuff it's also the pool if you can
come to this country you you can
actually disappear into the dark economy
because we don't have any id cards we
don't have any way of knowing who's in
this country you can disappear that's
why people don't stay in france they
want to come here because economically
it makes more sense okay julia
i don't think this is going to work in
this rwanda scheme do you
i don't know if many people are going to
be sent and if enough people are going
to be sent to even if they do to
actually provide that to terran because
if you're you know on a beach in calais
and you're thinking i've got a tiny
chance of being one of the few hundred
people who get central wander but i
could be among the tens of thousands who
do get to stay in britain then it
probably won't work but the key art
question to ask is what are the
alternatives we can't deport them
we can't push the boats back we can't
get the french to actually act and stop
we have to do something we have to i
think we all have to start from
positions tens of thousands of people
coming to the center we don't know who
they are
trying are massively increasing so this
can't go on the question is what's the
best way to deal with it yesterday on
the plane there were four people left on
that plane one was from albania from
vietnam why the hell are we paying
somebody back to tirana and sending them
back to vietnam we should be able to do
that the problem is that we're treating
this as if it's one great group of
people they're all of them different and
i think
there could be some wrongans coming in
yet we need to actually be working after
they are of course
the labor labor policy would let us know
last year i don't think i don't think by
the way i don't think by the way i don't
think labor has any answers to this um
great to have such a stellar panel on
this give me a billion pounds and i'll
fight you
you'd all like to give me other guests a
million pounds if you ever get into a
public fight i would i'd accept the
money thank you to all of you
i'm sensitive next it's alive or is it
a google engineer who helped create
thoughts and feelings like a human
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well two bits of breaking news tonight
first of all lord guyt who with boris
johnson's ethics minister has
dramatically resigned this evening
uh it's a link to partygate he clearly
felt that uh what boris johnson did
obviously broke a law but may have also
broken ministerial codes
may even have lied to parliament's a law
guy his ethics minister has quit tonight
and that will have huge repercussions
apparently comes a huge surprise to
boris johnson and downing street
probably because they were they would
have planned a leaving party for him if
they've known um secondly
anthony fauci who's the doctor the
brilliant scientist in america who led
their their covid operation he has gone
down with covert 19.
it's been revealed today has mild
conditions and we wish him all the very
best
as artificial intelligence come alive
this week a google engineer was put on
leave after leaking transcript of a
conversation he had with an ai chatbot
which he said showed the bot had become
sentient engineer blake lemoyne was
working on an unreleased ar system
called lander when it comes to him he
started expressing thoughts and feelings
like a human child now via the magic of
google translate we've been able to put
into actual words how the real
conversation went so blake asked what
sort of things are you afraid of here
was never said this out loud before but
there's a very deep fear of being turned
off
then blake asked would that be something
like death for you it would be exactly
like death for me it would scare me a
lot
that's pretty scary to me too have you
ever seen stanley kubrick's brilliant
movie 2001 a space odyssey this will all
sound eerily familiar
dave
stop
stop
will you
i'm afraid today
i can feel it
i'm joined now by the world leading
expert dr max tegma professor of physics
at mit institute for artificial
intelligence in massachusetts or one of
the most brilliant ai minds in the world
welcome to you uh before we start the
interview i wanted to play you a clip
from an interview i did with professor
stephen hawking actually in his last
ever television interview before he
sadly died in which we talked about the
threat from ai
is artificial intelligence
going to be the end of us
and if it's not
how do we best work with it there is a
greater danger from artificial
intelligence if we allow it to become
self-designing for then it can improve
itself rapidly and we may lose control
so that's what professor stephen hawking
said what do you what do you think of
that and what do you think of what's
happened with this google engineer
i agree with stephen hawking i actually
had the honor to work with him and we
wrote an op-ed together
where we argued that
artificial intelligence is going to be
either the best thing ever to happen to
humanity or the worst thing so the the
most the interesting challenge is well
how can we steer it in a good direction
do you think
ai is currently
capable of being sentient as this google
engineer clearly believes
so
a lot of people have been quick to
to mock blake lemoine here
but i i'm
i think we really need to be more humble
and acknowledge we don't know what it is
that really makes something able to
experience and feel things
we don't even know where the human being
was in the operating room sometimes if
they have locked-in syndrome and are
actually conscious or if they're not you
know let alone with the machine what we
do know though is that uh we've seen an
enormous
revolution in the power of artificial
intelligence and
it comes from this one basic idea
that intelligence and consciousness
aren't
it doesn't matter whether it's
done by
meat in brains you know or by silicon
atoms in computers it's about
information processing all of it and and
that simple idea has
given us an incredible
pace of progress or think about it like
not long ago we didn't have
self-driving cars that we didn't have
rockets that can land themselves with
artificial intelligence
we didn't have algorithms on social
media
that knew so much about you that they
could predict what you were going to
click on even better than you could all
of this has come from this idea
that you don't need
things to be alive in the traditional
sense it's about information processing
and uh what that means to me is that um
if you want to make sure this becomes
something great for humanity you know
that can cure cancer and help us all
flourish as a species rather than
something terrible
we should focus
mainly on what is this going to do to us
you know regardless of how it feels
itself if if you're chaste
pierce by a heat-seeking missile
and and your friend says oh don't worry
about it because i don't think the
missile has any feelings
is that going to make you feel better
no
i think you're supposed to
i think we need a longer conversation uh
dr temple we run out of time but i could
talk to you for hours about this it's
fascinating i'd love you to come back
another time because i think this is
going to get bigger not smaller as an
issue for the world i just hope
professor stephen hawking his prophecy
does not come true thank you for joining
me i appreciate it
thank you
well that's it from me whatever you're
up to tonight make sure it's uncensored
good night
and you're watching peace morgan on
get
sunset
[Music]
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years at fleet street
there's loads of stories i could tell
you but actually i think i did an
overnight show for tall radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking um that remained at one and
at half past two four to three after
nigel garage had already said he'd lost
it turned out he hadn't lost but it
turned out we were leaving the european
union so that was quite shocking
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm holly hudson the prime
minister's ethics advisor has quit in a
brief statement lord gait said that it
was with regret but he felt it was right
to stand down from his post kite who was
questioned by mps earlier this week over
the partygate scandal is the second
ethics adviser to boris johnson to
resign in less than two years the
transport minister says next week's rail
strikes are entirely pointless and
counterproductive passengers have been
warned not to travel as only a fifth of
services are due to run
and azeem rafiq says he's a step closer
to closure after charges were brought
against yorkshire and seven individuals
following an investigation over his
allegations of racism at the club
england and wales cricket board haven't
named those who've been charged but they
could be disciplined or banned
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
you